it's Thursday January seventh and that
marks the beginning of smites 2016 World
Championship hi-rez Studios is
celebrating with a ton of new content
season three of the MOBA is kicking off
with an all-new Japanese pantheon of
characters leaving the charges Amaterasu
who you might remember from the classic
okami smites version of the Sun Goddess
is totally different of course but her
talents and debuff should make her an
excellent choice on the battlefield when
she releases on January 12 also coming
in season 3 is a replacement for the
three-on-three joust map this one is
modeled after a legendary Chinese
skypalace there will be more characters
down the road but we don't know about
them just yet we do know that Japanese
theme skins are on the way though you
can see kaiju so back in Harajuku neat
in the trailer hi rez also said the
focus of season 3 is overall user
experience so expect plenty of support
the more content gets announced the more
we'll talk about it at gamespot now if
you'll excuse me I have some God's to
slay